[Music]
and welcome back to this very very
serious newscast everybody we've got mr
jesprit here with just kidding news for
the first time
thanks for having me very special off
the record careful boys episode where we
get to know you we like to share all the
greatness with our fans so tell us a
little bit about yourself what do people
know you for for online and then what
are the stuff they don't know hey you
looking sharp today nick thanks man
appreciate it plain black tea
yeah it's crazy back to jespery uh dr
jess
i appreciate that well thank you for
having me uh i think people know me
online as the minority mindset
and
i think because i talk about money
financial education investing things
that i wish i would have learned when i
was getting started
and i started minority mindset as a
hobby i started making videos just for
fun i got scammed in another business
that i was running
and and because i was so upset that
sounds really juicy by the way we'll go
back to it yeah we need to know about
that one because anthony gets scammed
all the time you know yeah he needs to
know the talent i like juice is what
he's trying to say yeah well you know
and so i was really upset so then i
started making videos off my phone about
just random things about business how to
not get screwed over
how to invest your money things that i
wish that i knew
and slowly that started to grow and
eventually this kept getting bigger and
bigger and i was in law school at the
time and i was like well i don't want to
be an attorney so i graduated law school
and i never worked a day as an attorney
damn i love how you still graduated
because you have to finish the thing is
i was the parent
i went to law school because my parents
gave me
two options when i was growing up i kill
you
that was one the other option was become
a doctor become a doctor or we'll kill
you those are the two options i choose
death
and so when they found out that i didn't
want to be a doctor they were like well
if you want to keep any pride in the
family you have to at least become an
attorney i love my parents they just
don't have that financial education but
i love them to death they were doing it
out of love right
but
i was like okay well i can go to law
school the nice thing about law school
is i know i can go there part-time work
in my business full-time and figure out
what i want to do really in life because
they just wanted to do school part-time
that's crazy well i wasn't i was
full-time for the first year and a half
and then i was part-time for the second
half because the first year was like the
toughest one so i just wanted to get
that out of the way the first year is a
tough one
i know nothing about law school yeah
either do i
so so law school it's not like uh like a
40 hour a week commitment type of thing
i mean
it's it's pretty time intensive law
school is tough you gotta study a lot
right yeah you gotta study a lot i think
i was able to figure out systems like i
was pretty nice where like so there's
this thing called um outlines right
where if you can get like especially the
spark notes of your class
and so i was able to become friends with
people and there was these like services
online where you could pay money to get
outlines for classes and i was like well
i tried reading the textbooks
and like i don't know for sure if i'm
dyslexic but english is my second
language so i don't read very well like
i can't read very well at all i listen
to audiobooks because i suck at reading
so i tried reading these textbooks
i got nowhere so i was like this is not
gonna work so i tried looking for
alternatives so that's when i started
paying for these outlines on classes
because it's pretty much the same across
the country like when you're learning
constitutional law it's a little bit
different but if you're learning from a
particular textbook like you know what
you got to know yeah so i would uh just
buy these and then become friends with a
lot of people and then they would share
their outlines from the year before so i
would just study these outlines and you
started slaying outlines
businessman gave him up for free though
for me i never charged anybody because i
was like you know you're a
philanthropist man of the people the
philanthropist
yeah exactly so i gave away these
outlines for free so people hooked me up
with their outlines and uh it got me
through law school i liked learning but
i was really bad at the traditional
studying like when it came to the bar
exam i did really good on the bar exam
not so but i but i struggled a lot to
like i failed which is kind of funny i
failed one of my classes there and it's
one of the most important classes for
like traditional attorneys
[Laughter]
we had this class called evidence which
is like if you want to become like a
born area is really important if you
want to like ever do anything in the
court system you have to be really good
at this and the the
teacher that we had the professor he was
appointed judged by president george
bush so it's like a really high up
professor
very intense and i failed his class and
like he picked on me because he was very
tough he would like call you out in
class and he would pick on me multiple
times and i never knew anything that he
asked
so i like man i feel really bad that i
can embarrass myself in this class but i
just couldn't
understand some of that stuff i
understood the business side i
understood the tax side understood the
the like financial side of laws but the
the traditional like you know you're i'm
gonna sue you type of law i didn't it
just did not click with me so if you had
to be a lawyer what type of lawyer would
you be if i had to build i'd probably
work somewhere on the business side
working with businesses uh helping them
but not the suing side of business
cycles and acquisitions
i got i'll tell you because i when i got
sued uh i got sued when um right before
i went to law school i was investing in
real estate right and uh i got sued by
a tenant in one of my real estate
properties who sued my real estate
company because they said the bathtub
was too slippery when the water was on
and that caused uh the person
living it's too slippery yeah no it's
true that's like a snl skin yeah so no
it's
there's too much liquid in this [ __ ]
coffee yeah and so uh you know it's like
they won didn't they no they didn't win
but they didn't get like 14 grand as a
settlement
because the
insurance says either we're gonna have
to litigate it pay three to five hundred
dollars an hour to the attorney to beat
them or we just give them 14 grand to
make them go away
right so you look at the pros and cons
and that's the unfortunate you know you
talk about what kind of law is is
[ __ ] it's across the board
a lot of attorneys are just
not the whole system is just a money
grab like the
there's no right or wrong ethically
right it's like you can sue anybody for
anything mcdonald's got sued or somebody
got sued because they don't have enough
cheese in their uh cheese sticks we're
in the wrong business guys yeah but it
just seems like money grabs in those
situations just from my own
understanding if somebody settles right
in that situation can somebody else
sue you again for the same thing because
it never
like
it was just a settlement that was like
private if
if
so when you do a settlement you're going
to make a contract saying that you
cannot sue me anymore for that's what
i'm saying somebody somebody else the
other tenants hear about it attendant
says oh we slipped and fell into bath
because it's too slippery yeah i guess
you technically could with it but then
you would probably have a new
policy for that rental property where
you have to wear shoes in the bathtub
yeah you gotta wear timberlands the
first settlement you'd already added
into the leasing right yeah you gotta
learn from your mistakes and then your
only shoes in the bathtub and they have
to sign it that's why you always see
those crazy rules on contracts sometimes
you're like somebody [ __ ] up exactly
that's all it was that's why those
contracts you signed are 50 pages long
when they should just be like two
paragraphs because something bad goes
wrong and then like
it just keeps getting like like for
example in our contracts we have to do
like the most basic things make sure you
change the smoke detector every six
months if you see bed bugs let us know
why because
things have gone wrong where people are
like oh i didn't change the smoke
detector for eight months and then
they make a claim to somebody else and
it's just it's dumb stuff where it's
like common sense doesn't exist in some
of these cases so um when you're in law
school you also had rental properties
when did that journey start like so i
started buying rental properties when i
was 19. wow
what what got you to be so responsible
can i be in your family yeah yeah
are you adopting
so and the courage well let me let me
back up a little bit because
so
my parents wanted me to be a doctor so
much that if i did anything that wasn't
related to becoming a doctor it was
considered bad like i played football in
high school they did not want me to play
football because it's a distraction it's
like being a criminal yeah it's it's
being it's that's like his rebellious
nature he's like well fine i'm gonna go
purchase rental properties yeah yeah
that's your belt that's what connects
all asians together is we're forced to
be doctors exactly right
so my parents
for my outlet was entrepreneurship and
um i started hosting teen parties when i
was in high school i was working at
indian weddings and so i got to know a
lot of the local djs
and then they were like yeah you know a
lot of friends in high school
um how about we host some teen parties
with your friends there and there was an
indian restaurant that opened up they
wanted exposure and i knew the person
because i ate there and he was like well
yeah we can do something
so we made a deal where he wouldn't
charge us anything we could host parties
there and he would get exposure so
that's what i did we started hosting
these like teen parties for 16 17 year
old kids to come and dance and have fun
um i wasn't into partying i didn't drink
i didn't smoke i still don't do any of
that but for me it was it was fun it was
just a hobby and a way for me to make a
little bit of money because we charge
cover
um but i didn't tell my parents so this
is something i was doing kind of a
secret
and then in the back of my mind i knew
that you know this is just a hobby i got
to become a doctor because that's how
i'm going to become successful because i
want to take care of my family and my
community
but then i go to college and my parents
didn't go to university here i don't
know what to expect i thought everybody
goes to college to study uh become a
doctor do this big thing in college
study on friday nights right that's
right exactly just like my man right
here right mom that's like wearing a
suit not a devry
idt tech baby you got it wrong with this
today's video is brought to you by
audible
you know
i've been uh trying to figure out how
come every time i invest money i lose
money
so i was like
i think i need to learn some things you
know is this the book that you told me
about too yeah so psychology of money
yeah it's a good one yeah i started i
started listening to it because as you
guys know when i drive from vegas to la
i got like four hours and that's the
best time for me to listen because also
when i read stuff
sometimes it doesn't retain i'm reading
the same sentence over and over and over
but when someone tells tells it to me i
retain the knowledge way better so if
you guys want to understand way more not
about the how to's of investing but
like the psychology
and the philosophy behind it check it
out psychology of money it's on audible
and you get one title per month on
audible so you can switch out books all
the time and you get audible originals
podcasts you get so much more content
than just audio books so let audible
help you discover new ways to laugh be
inspired or be entertained new members
can try it free for 30 days visit
audible.com off the record or text off
the record to 500 500 that's audible.com
off the record or text off the record to
500 500 to try audible for free for 30
days and in 30 days you can read a whole
book by listening
audible.com off the record so i go to
college and i think everybody does this
and i get there and i don't know what to
bring because again you know i i told my
mom i was like and i say this in my
native language punjabi said mom which
means i'm leaving she was like where as
i'm going to college she's like okay
when you're coming back i said i don't
know maybe next week i didn't know
anything so i like i picked out my car i
took a microwave a sleeping bag
um my backpack and like two other things
i didn't have a towel i didn't even have
a blanket like i had literally had no
idea what i was supposed to take to
college so i go there but you brought
him my microphone
so it worked you know
and so now i go there and i see
everybody partying blowing money
drinking
where do you have all this money from
you know i was like first off like i
thought everybody was like broke in
college yet everyone's here at the bar
spending money like it's their job and i
don't know what was going on so i was
like well i don't drink i don't smoke
i'm not into parties but i need
something to do so i took this party
idea that i had in high school and i was
like well let's go to college and let's
try this so 17 started knocking on the
door of every club when you borrow a
restaurant trying to see if somebody
would let me do a party there
and some of them were like yo you need
10 grand to do a party i don't got 10
grand but eventually i found a club that
was like you can do a party here we're
not going to charge you any money but we
want 50 of your cover of the revenue
right that you bring in so i was like
all right we can do that so we made that
deal and i started hosting parties there
and i didn't have money to pay the dj
either so i said all right look how
about you do 50 50 with me so the club
takes 50 of the revenue off the top then
out of the 50 you take half and i take
half so i was taking only 25 of the
revenue but it cost me nothing yeah so i
was like we're in business so i started
doing that and that business uh started
to grow
relatively quickly i got screwed over in
the first one
because the the club industry
entertainment industry is a very dirty
industry you deal with some very rough
stuff like i remember one time i went to
the club i was like you know where's uh
the manager he's like oh we got stabbed
last night
so you know you deal with a lot of crazy
stuff so i was an assistant manager
he's in jail
for stabbing the manager
that's the type of stuff he had to deal
with right i mean there's like physical
stuff i had to go through because like
there's always fights people get drunk
and there was a lot of like beef between
different like i don't want to say gangs
but different types of people so i was
there i was the one breaking it all
apart physically
playing football because i played
football
oh you played football i played football
in high school yeah
but uh in high school not college i was
nowhere near good enough to play in
college my dad only i wanted to my dad
was like well you can play football in
college if you go to medical school
straight out of high school
these stipulations you could only be in
the nfl if you're a surgeon
you go in the searching round
so
i was making a little bit of money and i
had some cash in the bank um from doing
this
and uh now i'm starting to become a
doctor in between my sophomore year and
junior year i'm studying for the mcat
which is a test you take to get into
medical school what was your major was
like a science major
psychology it's much it sounds a lot
smarter than it is so it's called
biopsychology cognition and neuroscience
that's what my major was no way it's
psychobio psychobiology so it sounds
smart but obviously it's not we get it
but it's the dumbest major in the
sciences department
that's how mine was to when i picked my
classes the only thing that the main
thing that i looked for was which room
the class was in because
uh the big classroom had these reclining
seats kind of like this so i can
close my eyes and fall asleep so that's
that was the main requirement that i had
mine was i remember ratemyprofessor.com
oh yeah yeah so i'll look i'm like okay
which one of these sciences is the
easiest because we're trying to do
youtube at the time too i'm like i can't
be doing some of these hard signs so i
got to actually study he was trying to
go pre-med too yeah i studied for the
mcat yeah i took did you take it no i
took um got princeton i took princeton
too yeah i was just going through the
whole process yeah hating life more and
more and more yeah
i mean that was it was tough and so same
thing i was studying losing my mind yeah
and i was starting to read these
business books and every business book
said that wealthy people invest in real
estate i had no idea what that meant
because i don't have investor family
members i don't know what real estate
investing is i've never heard of anybody
doing that but i told my dad i said dad
i want to invest in real estate because
wealthy people are doing it because
you're stupid go study become a doctor
and then invest in real estate
again i love my dad he's a huge
supporter now like my biggest father but
you just don't know right you don't know
what you don't know you don't know yeah
and uh so i'm 19 studying for this and
this is at the bottom of the 2008 crash
and michigan was hit especially hard
right kid 4 gm chrysler uh all were hit
so hard
and so i'm looking at you know the
financial news that says real estate's
at rock bottom i'm reading these books
it says wealthy people invest in real
estate
and you bought the dip uh i it's exactly
what i did i took the mcat on august
22nd on august 23rd i bought my first
rental property
for eight grand wow wow
eight grand
well is that total all in that was the
price of the condo i spent maybe a
couple grand or a little bit on the
repairs is it because it was detroit it
wasn't it was a suburb of detroit very
nice suburb good school district that
same condo sold for 150 000 just a few
years prior
and then i didn't know any i thought it
was normal because again this is this is
the first time i've ever exposed
anything related to finance right i had
no idea
what investing was what real estate
investing was what how real estate works
so i went in and bought it and it was
actually listed for 8 400.
i made an offer for four grand they came
down to 7 000 and i was still going back
to fourth but then they said they had
another offer on the table big dick move
huh like an asian old man dude that's so
funny offering four grand for a condo
just sounds so that was live dude i
didn't know anything better i was like
if it's listed for 8 400 i would i don't
know like 4 000 like i can afford that i
bought it for eight grand and then i uh
listed it and we got attended it for six
hundred dollars a month wow and uh oh
my gosh what was your mortgage like 50
bucks no mortgage cash about the cash
cash what's the reason it went down so
much so the 2008 crash um when the whole
real estate market exploded
the car and so michigan especially then
was almost entirely the auto industry
ford gm and chrysler gm went bankrupt
chrysler bankrupt ford was on the verge
of bankruptcy thanks to the good old
japanese yeah you put them out of
business brother
that happened and uh the car market got
hit man and michigan was hit hard saw
the employees also boys lost their jobs
we're gonna make the mortgages there's a
lot of bad things happening in the
lending industry
uh but it was a bad time and again like
i didn't know this was abnormal and i
joke about this now because i remember
when i was buying property started
bonding for like 10 grand 20 grand 30
grand i was buying nice homes in good
areas
and i remember when home prices went up
to 50 000
i was like that is an outrageous price
who is gonna pay 50 grand for this four
bedroom two bath home in a nice area
yeah i i i was like i'm not paying for
this is way overpriced i never looked at
that property in l.a at least two three
hundred thousand dollars now and what's
crazy i remember i the uh i don't know
if i say a mistake but a funny thing
that i did was i took my mom because i
was like i want to go through this with
somebody and my mom was like well maybe
i could work as a real estate sales
person or something so i took it through
these like properties i was looking for
at five grand they were listed for five
grand they needed like
new carpet new paint
and
my mom was like oh these are disgusting
i was like yeah but you know i can just
put a new carpet and paint it look nice
there's like no don't buy this is dirty
and i and those same homes are probably
two hundred thousand dollars now wow
they probably needed five to ten
thousand dollars worth of work there and
uh it's crazy because i i didn't realize
how crazy it was until now i'm a little
bit smarter because i was like really
dumb like i made every mistake possible
uh during that time but you learn cheap
that's how you learn yeah thank god i
learned cheap but i learned um i learned
the hard way would you say your gains
back then are higher than the gains now
oh yeah man i mean i mean because i
haven't sold um i've only signed one
thing so i mean those are the returns on
joe's you're a huddler too huh well yeah
you buy and hold man that's the
it's much easier when you have a real
asset that's producing cash flow you
know so
so yeah that's how it all started for me
and then um just continued then then i
was like oh well
finishing up college and i was like you
know this entertainment industry is a
dirty industry and i don't like drinking
i'm promoting the wrong things this is
not me i i i really like i never hated
uh doing anything as much as i hated
that because like out i was doing it for
all the wrong reasons i was doing it
because i was making money uh i was
doing it because it was the only thing
that i knew and i was like well i gotta
make money so this is what i'm gonna do
and i was doing it for all the wrong
reasons it wasn't me
it wasn't anything that i supported so i
got out of that and then i went on like
this trying trying trying different
businesses trying to figure out what to
do and that was rough you know because
like you try start something make a
little bit money you're like oh that's
not what i want to do and you start over
yeah what would what would be your i
guess not cash cal but your thing that
you kind of focused on and then that
kind of got you to a point before you
started youtube well i would say i was
buying a lot of real estate i was buying
as much like any time i was living very
small and
i guess the best example i can give was
like
i was making about 100 grand a year
or so and i was in school
and my apartment
including all the utilities parking
water electric uh
heat and um
internet less than 400 a month
so i was spending nothing because i
wanted to
invest as much as i could because these
michigan prices [ __ ] we're in the wrong
state did you get a new microwave at
least uh did you get a towel i think
that microwave was actually my grandma's
i took and um
i still got it i forgot that microwave
yeah so old microwaves don't break man
so that's how it all started and then
you know just freaking things out and
then just just a lot of different
businesses man i just i started failed
potentially got sued in some i tried to
start this amazon business with a really
good friend of mine it was one of my dj
friends one of my best friends and we
you know we come up with ideas like oh
we could buy this stuff from china and
sell it on this thing called amazon oh
and he was like dude forget amazon we
could do ebay this is before amazon
really became amazon right and i was
like well let's try it
and we started buying these um
these uh phone accessories and
we were told that it's an authorized
retailer that they're like legitimate
that they're certified so any if we can
buy it from them that we can sell it
anywhere that we want i was like all
right let's do this so
we started buying these and we bought
like a
a small order and we sold them all out
like in a week we're like whoa we
figured it out so now we started buying
a bunch we were selling them on ebay
then we started selling them on amazon
and we were making like probably 100 a
day in profits and you know we're like
19 or something doing this um online so
it's a lot of money so really dude we're
making a crap ton of money like we got
to do more and then
the real
company sent us a letter saying well
we're gonna sue you for seven million
dollars because you're selling uh
counterfeit products
and we looked at each other and i was
like
what like we thought they were
legitimate so we shut the entire
business down we were so scared because
like
where we're gonna get this type of money
we don't even know what insurance we
don't have insurance we don't even know
what insurance was at the time
so we we shut that down ran away really
quick so yeah you learn fast
but it's it's a lot of times getting
punched in the mouth and trying
something new
is that uh
kind of the same going back to the the
the how you got screwed over by a
business partner yeah it's that's a
little bit different so my my thing is
anytime i start something new i get
screwed over and that's been a trend so
if i go back to the party business
when i was in college i started my first
party and uh my first party i spent so
much time effort trying to plan and
promote it because i wanted it to be a
big banger like you know the
the announcement of this company the
announcement the first party so i want
everybody to have a good time and i was
working with this club owner
and we had everything figured out
planned out
and the night
before the event
uh
somebody was at somebody that my dj knew
was at the club and the club got raided
by the cops
because i guess they were serving
underage
alcohol or something like that right i
don't know what they were doing but
something like that
and uh
so they got ready they got shut down i
didn't get a call no one told me so now
it's the day of the event and my dj
calls me 10 in the morning he's like yo
what's going on with the event what are
you talking about it's like i heard that
the club got shut down i was like what
are you talking about so now i start
blowing up the the owner's phone and i
was like yo
what's going on he wasn't answering
until like and i didn't hear from him
for like two hours
and that's when i found out the club got
shut down so now we have all this
marketing promotion going on for this
event that doesn't have a venue so then
uh now i'm scrambling to find um a new
spot we finally found this really nice
italian restaurant in ann arbor that
agreed to host this
uh
very elegant event the way that i put it
because i just needed a place to do it
right any time about ann arbor um it's
really nice place and
we did the event there and it was so bad
i mean there was fights these people
just started they had these light bulbs
that cost 250 dollars a piece people
just started breaking them for no reason
because they were just like dangling and
it was horrible so we lost a lot of
money and
i
they were right next to uh comerica
which is where i was banking then
they're like yo these are the damages
and they had no way to go after me but i
was like i felt so bad that i went to my
bank account i said just cash i was like
look how's all the money that i have wow
they're like you know it's fine like
thank you for that we'll take care of
the expenses so i wanted to make sure i
take care of them just because morally i
felt bad yeah i lost money because now
uh you know we had no way of collecting
cash because they're a restaurant like
they didn't have any system but the
party people had a great time so people
had a great time so the street cred is
still good street cred was good but i
lost a lot of money but again you know
that was horrible but i made it back
then uh with the amazon thing that
happened
then i was started the sock company
later on um
which ritu yeah i went through a lot and
so this was uh
uh this other
i was taking this class um on public
speaking
and a buddy of mine my roommate was like
you gotta watch this show called shark
tank you're gonna love it i was like
okay whatever right i don't really watch
tv
and it was really cool it's about people
pitching ideas i was like oh this is fun
and um
the class was like we're going to do
kind of like a shark tank thing where
you have to pitch a product to the class
i was like oh that's easy i watch shark
tank all the time so i procrastinated i
didn't do anything and then uh
i was late one day i picked up my
backpack and it was raining and i
started running to class
and as i'm running i stepped in the
puddle now my socks wet i sit down and
the teacher's like it's your day to
present like present what and she's like
present the speech the the talk and i
was like oh and so i stand up in front
of the class i'm sitting there like just
breathe think of any product think of
anything just just say something
my first idea were these wet socks
what if you could have athletic socks
that didn't get wet and i pitched it for
like 15 minutes or whatever i needed to
do and i sat down i was like that's a
cool idea
that's a great idea yeah you're good at
winging it man shark tank yourself dude
so and then i i was like so then i went
home i was like does this exist and they
had like these like really clunky ugly
looking ones like hmm i wonder if i
could do this so then i went on this
mission to see if i could create these
water resistant socks and i figured out
that if i can create this take a certain
type of cotton and this other product
and blend it with this other technology
which exists i can license it i can
create this water resistant sock that's
what i did so then i launched this uh
sock company
and it's called stance it was called
five water socks and um
during the launch uh right before the
launch i had this marketing company
reach out to me saying oh we can promise
you all these sales blah blah we'll do
all this and then
and they're like we want 3 500
but it's a hundred percent money-back
guarantee if you don't love it we'll
give you your money back i was like okay
that sounds good so i gave them the
money the next day literally the next
day i go to the gym and i'm doing chest
flies and i remember this because i was
like i had a really bad feeling in my
stomach which doesn't normally happen so
i called him up i was like hey man you
know what let's just cancel it you'd
refine me the money before you spend any
money give me the money back and i'll do
the marketing myself because i'm a
marketer i like marketing
and uh
he's like sure no problem puts me on
hold and i was getting really frustrated
because i'm in between sets and someone
hold
a couple minutes
i always get really frustrated and then
the line just goes beep
yeah and then so they just took your
money i found out they were a scam yeah
they took the money and i never heard
from again
what the [ __ ] but when we launched we
had a very did they have a nigerian
accent no he did it it was prince was it
it wasn't a nigerian prince this time it
wasn't a prince this time but i lost
that money and then we launched the
company still did great i think we did
like
21 000
of pre-orders in the first 30 days so it
was really good and um
but i was that's when i got so upset i
was like this sucks man like i've been
through so much crap i never learned a
thing about investing i never learned to
think about entrepreneurship i keep
getting screwed over like there's no
resource for people like me trying to
figure it out so that's when i started
making videos aren't you like getting
screwed over like succeeding every
single time you get screwed over yeah
well you know gas parties still twenty
one thousand dollars in the first month
hundreds of dollars per day as a
nineteen year old
dude it sucks man every time
you see a bank account like this and
pull back down and it goes up and then
boom back down
[Music]
you